i'm rodney scott barbecue pit master and
restaurant owner and today i will be
answering your questions on twitter this
is barbecue support
[Music]
first up from
daniel huggs is there a difference
between grilling and barbecuing isn't
barbecue when it has barbecue sauce
there is a difference between grilling
and barbecuing grilling is when you're
open flame pretty hot and fast
barbecuing is when you're low and slow
barbecue sauce that's your personal
preference
next up from lucifer's kyo noah wait how
do you make barbecue sauce what goes
into it barbecue sauce can be a base of
vinegar it can be a base of pepper or
molasses and you can make barbecue sauce
pretty much in your own personal flavors
you can create or you can follow along
with any recipes that you've seen heard
of or experienced
in six four mcdonald's barbecue sauce
thoughts drive on through next up
joe's real barbecue asks how do you make
your brisket sandwich brisket is a beef
cut from the chest of the cow kind of
like the peck of the cow you can make
your brisket sandwich either chopped or
sliced the way i do it is chopped and
sliced slices basically against the
grain with a touch of fattiness in there
the chopped brisket sandwich which is
just what it says chopped brisket you
can add cheese thick sauce no sauce at
all there's so many different ways you
can make a brisket sandwich next
basket savor what is your favorite tool
to barbecue with my favorite tool to
barbecue with is a long pair of tongs
like such
a long tongue is important because you
want to make sure and have nice
clearance when you're reaching in to
rotate your proteins or to grab your
vegetables when you're cooking on a
grill and if you're making a sauce my
second favorite tool
is a whisk to make sure you get all your
ingredients stirred in when you're
making your barbecue sauce
next up arctic cabin ltd asks what are
the best cuts of meat for barbecuing if
it's beef i would say bone in rib eye
it's great protein doesn't take long to
cook and it doesn't take a lot of
seasoning on the grill if it's chicken
leg quarter because it's a little fatty
and it stays juicier on the grill and if
it's pork pork shoulder because you get
a combination of the shoulder and a
little bit of the top of the ribs
perfect cut daryl fazz ass smoke a
brisket fat side up or fat side down fat
side up because that fat renders down
and flavors the rest of the brisket
carnie250 says
what is a barbecue style a barbecue
style is a recognition of a general area
there are several styles of barbecue you
have what they call texas style which is
more of a beef base it is served without
sauce you have some st louis styles
where some of them are dry rub a memphis
style that's used with a dry rub there's
the carolina style which is mostly
either mustard or vinegar out of all of
those my favorite is carolina because
that's what i grew up on that's what i
love the most and that's what we serve
to this day chavez chris laughing my ass
off what's so special about texas
barbecue texas is known for barbecue i
highly respect everybody in texas that
cooks barbecue not only is it celebrated
it's also cooked without any sauces and
is using just basic ingredients most of
the time of kosher salt and black pepper
and all the natural flavors come out
through the smoke and it's so celebrated
in texas as well as around the world the
road diaries ask are fall off the bone
baby back ribs overcooked
yes next
nosy gero siri how do you roast a pig
low and slow baby low and slow you want
to make sure when your pig is laid on
the grate meat side down that you only
apply your heat to the hams and the
shoulders those are the thickest parts
every 10 to 15 minutes maintaining a
temperature between 225 to 250. this is
about 135 to 160 pound hog and this
should be about a 10 to 12 hour cook
time next up prairie joe's what's a pit
master
do you need a phd a pit master is
considered to be a person that's cooking
barbecue without any gauges any modern
utensils or gadgets just cooking with
the basics and no you don't need a phd
to be a pit master
next up orgasmic chef
which type of barbecue do you prefer a
brick built one that burns wood or
charcoal or propane burning one the
flavors on propane are kind of not as
flavorful as wood a little bit more
bland i prefer brick pit and i can
actually show you that now
you can burn your wood down get
charcoals you will get the natural
flavors of wood smoke and everything
that's so nice if you're using charcoal
i prefer to use a wood lump charcoal
it's a great natural flavor and it's as
close as you can get with buying
charcoal next breed d hellinger asks i
know this is off topic but i am making
my first pulled pork tomorrow any tips
or tricks if you're doing your first
pulled pork that can be a pork shoulder
that can be a pork butt either or you
want to make sure and start with the
meat side down cook it to about 165 to
190 degrees to make sure that your pork
is cooked all the way through once you
reach that temperature of 190 you're
able to pull it apart without any other
utensils other than your hands that's
why it's nicknamed pulled pork and when
you turn it over increase the heat just
a little to get the skin nice and crispy
and add your sauce of your choice
stromile pdx
ask any tips recipes for making beef
brisket if you're going to cook your
brisket i recommend that you put your
offset of having the colds on one side
and the brisket on the other and always
be sure to check for a tip next up foul
g too much seasoning or nah and this
looks like a pitcher of a brisket with
some seasoning on it
and it looks like kosher salt and pepper
seasoning is a personal preference you
just don't want it too salty or too
spicy young jojobi unanswered questions
what does the q stand for in barbecue
quality
next char griller what's your best tip
of perfect ribs you want to take the
membrane off your ribs so you can allow
the rub that you're using to kind of go
all the way through to the bone as you
can see the ribs are
membrane off dry rub
you get a little caramelization from the
brown sugar you have that tenderness not
fall off the bone
but just easy enough to chew
and if you put your rib on a grill
that's way too hot it's going to burn
before it starts to cook and you also
want them to cook nice and brown on one
side where you can get a nice char and
flip them over let them cook on the
other side to temp which is 165 degrees
kevin's barbecue joints why is barbecue
so special barbecue is so special
because it's one of those moments in
times that so many people come together
celebrate either an event or just a
gathering for people to forget about all
of your day-to-day roles marietta
smokehouse what's the advantage of
cooking on racks in the pan versus right
on the grate of a smoker cooking with a
rack in a pan you trap all the juices in
the flavors versus the grill a lot of
your fat is going to render down into
the hot coals and steam back up you'll
still get flavor but not quite as much
as you would get if it's in a pan next
up greg
gossa 2 this is a smoker setup using 130
pound hog cut in half sun's graduation
is at 4 reception at five how many hours
early is too early and we're looking at
a offset smoker with a hot box on the
end and my advice to you greg is you
need to start at least 13 hours earlier
to your 4 o'clock and you need to make
sure and have enough time to pull and
prepare for the 5 o'clock reception
always allow yourself an extra hour from
the cook time which averages about 12
hours now if you rush your hog their
chances are you can get a flare up which
we don't want and that can destroy your
hog you can rush it to a point where you
burn it and it's no good it'll be tough
and you just have to throw the whole
thing away
bbq confessions barbecue rubs wet or dry
and why i would have to say both because
i'm a lover of both wet and dry mostly
wet because it's not as gritty dry on
occasions because it's just so good
barbecuing bottles
love me some short ribs how do you prep
these here we have a picture of short
ribs all stacked up my suggestion to you
is to take some olive oil kind of rub on
your short rib and you want to go with a
kosher salt and some black pepper you
can add any other ingredient that you
wish to like garlic powder or maybe a
little bit of cayenne sure choice
matthew sonja asked what is a critical
barbecue size for you for me a critical
barbecue side is definitely the baked
beans for the baked beans i like to make
them nice and slow with bell pepper a
little brown sugar a little barbecue
sauce added some proteins if you already
have some smoked would be a great
addition to your baked beans next joy
sunnism i don't think i've ever had
really good coleslaw where do i find it
and how do i make it a really good
coleslaw starts with cabbage carrots or
salt and pepper in there touch of
vinegar and of course it's all tossed in
a dressing that's mayo mayo-based from
alien genoqueen
i'm such a big fan of barbecue like who
invented this the story goes that
hispaniole is where barbecue was started
by the spanish and the british i think
it was born in the carolinas
cinder's barbecue asks what does the
future of barbecue look like bright i
feel like it's going to be so
international all over the world it's
going to be one of the best and most
celebrated things in the entire world
stuffmotherland asks okay tweets come
and rep your steak who has the best
barbecue
you do
all right that's it i hope you all
learned something go out and enjoy your
barbecue